Avatar the way of water is an
overwhelming Feast for the senses but
one showstopping scene just might
overwhelm your emotions warnings
spoilers ahead breathe the themes of the
original Avatar aren't exactly subtle
the plot May Center on blue aliens
trying to protect a Magic Tree but at
its core it's a tale of colonialism
capitalism and the Follies of exploiting
the planet it's a movie in tune with the
forces of nature and director James
Cameron doubled down on those
environmentalism themes for the
long-awaited follow-up this time around
an avatar the way of water Jake Sully
and his family are Freedom Fighters
desperately trying to get the sky people
AKA the humans off of their Land once
and for all however once Jake's family
puts itself in danger and he realizes he
has a Target on his back from a newly
reborn Colonel quarrych they decide to
travel to the metcaina clan to hide and
make new lives for themselves while the
first film was all about the forest this
time we get a glimpse of a more
ocean-based biome where beings live in
harmony on a coastal Reef of course that
Harmony is quickly upended once humans
and the villainous avatars make
themselves known I need you
with me and I need you to be strong
humans apparently haven't learned any
lessons since the last time they were on
Pandora they've established a new base
of operations which involves regularly
sending out a battleship to meet its
quota what's that quota you ask you're
gonna regret asking that in an extended
sequence humans deploy a variety of
methods to subdue a Tolkien which is an
incredibly intelligent whale-like
creature that's able to communicate with
the Met kaina Clan the toll can also
share an appreciation of music and
Mathematics so it's clear these aren't
just Mindless animals but thanks to a
rare substance hidden within the Tolkien
that prevents human aging they're a high
value Target for the invading humans we
see just how corrupt and horrific
mankind can be during a scene when they
hunt to Tolkien to death to extract the
valuable material inside of it and to
make the scene even more heartbreaking
the tolkien's calf Remains by its
deceased parents side the whole time
later the mechaina clan as well as the
Sully family visit the deceased Tolkien
which was left in the ocean to function
as a kind of message to any of the navi
who might think of Crossing humans on
top of that the tolkien's calf is now
dead too adding further heartbreak to
the story on the one hand it's
understandable why this sequence was
necessary for the film it shows the
callous cruelty of humanity which sees
no problem in killing innocent creatures
just so a few Rich jerks can prevent
some wrinkles from forming plus it makes
it all the more satisfying to watch the
humans on the ship get the ever-loving
crud beaten out of them later on
especially when it comes to the death of
Captain mix scoresby who gets his arm
taken off for good measure foreign
not to feel a sense of grief for the
innocent Tolkien who died to set up the
action throughout the film we learn
about the Tolkien way and how
emotionally intelligent these creatures
are to see them die in front of us is
hard to watch but James Cameron does
have an act for pulling at viewers
Heartstrings
I'll never let go
[Music]
[Music]